der föhn tobt den indern kirchen es ist
der 22 november 2007 in der turnhalle
treffen sich die bürger zur
gemeindeversammlung denke aber dass
keine verfassung eingesetzt und auch die
bibel nicht einen exklusiven
alleinanspruch auf die nutzung von
gemeinsamen gut wie zb naturlandschaft
etc zu leisten schützt die damen zählen
die erholsame bieten die teils ohne
partner längst an das königreich von
einer einziger sie brachten den honig
selbst der natur mannschaft muss für
alle da sie meist zu lassen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zuhinterst im gegenteil hinter 25
lawinen zügen öffnen sich die berge zu
engstlenalp der sagenhafte ort ist zu
einem schauplatz des streits geworden
im mittelpunkt steht fritz immer den
seine gegner den könig der engstlenalp
nennen
willi könig deshalb denkt der oso
verhaute zimmer wird hier im sommer und
seit einigen jahren auch im winter
vorbereitet
das war pokal und stock
das sieht sie das ist eigentlich das
ganze dorf mitmacht rohstoffsicherung
gebracht
[Musik]
und das ist das reich des königs an
einem kalten winterwochen die ängste in
1850 meter über meer gemeinde
innertkirchen berner oberland bis jetzt
noch vielleicht nicht mehr lange
eines der wenigen alpentäler das
unberührt ist von lärm und fröhlichkeit
des massenhaften skivergnügen
[Musik]
und was spielt sich nicht
heute unser ziel ist der roadster flogen
und wir werden all die menge hoch
steigen und dann gibt halten wir jetzt
nicht von ihnen sind dagegen die
verlosten gibt eine kurze abfahrt der
flasche güte lagerte auf der engstlenalp
mark twain einsteigen einer der
entschiedensten orte der alpen berühmte
john kinder der erstbesteiger des songs
seit vier generationen bewirtet die
familie immer gäste hier oben auf der
engstlenalp sachen 100 und 750 + mode
eigentlich auf der anderen sind dem hot
titels hat man in denkt sagt oskar stöß
errichtet in dem hotelzimmer
und das hat sie schon gezeigt dass das
eigentlich wenig ist sie 1800 minsk -
großvater blond mit meinem großvater
zangen und einen ins und zweien enzkreis
das rote buch übrigens nur genau so
stammt der song im tiefen in sky mikro
und mitbürgern und die heim nachher beim
buchmacher gut 100 jahre lagen zwischen
bau und umbau des hotels ängste leid
aber noch erinnert die einrichtung der
zimmer an die bescheidenheit der alten
zeiten und das gästebuch ist ein
geschichten oder bricht in frage sagt
vom ersten rückstand heute den ersten
august 1883 samstags kommen wir sechsmal
hoch auf diese art von engelberg groß
und waren sehr
überrascht von der schönheit des sees
und umliegenden berge welche
unwillkürlich erinnerungen von st
moritzersee im engadin zurückrufen
[Musik]
aber noch jemand schwelgt in alten
erinnerungen
das ist hanspeter wenger garagist in
interlaken
der mann der dem könig das reich
streitig macht oder wie es fritz immer
vermutet der mann hinter dem aufstand
der mann der vielleicht kaiser werden
möchte dass ich die gute fee ohne die
waren ohne die wand was ich diese frau
in den kühlen büroräumen wärmen ihn die
erinnerungen seiner jugend und das
hinaus bilder von ängsten auch das ist
ein vorwurf zu sagen was bin ich mit 14
jahren getragen ist raus das ist pop
habe noch viele stoßen 50 stück
vertrauen sind also 52
schon aus ruinen erwirkt sind und auch
pannen und fehlern er sich der ort der
kraft und der kommunen und mit 17 jahren
hat hans peter benger in einem holzstock
die ersten autos repariert heute besitzt
er die größte garage von interlaken
er beschäftigt 41 mitarbeiter und ist
gerade daran seinen betrieb zu
vergrößern
aber seine große sehnsucht liegt weitab
vom wehren der stadt dort wo die sommer
seiner kindheit verbrachte war wohl
und auch hanspeter wenger besitzt einem
motorschlitten genau wie fritz immer
1999 hat er von der alpgenossenschaft
eine hütte gemietet und seither
erweitert er das touristische angebot
auf der engstlenalp im november 2007 hat
die bürgerschaft von innertkirchen einer
änderung des zonenplans zugestimmt
deshalb darf hanspeter wenger jetzt auch
mit dem schnee touristen entlang des
westens es führen hin und her zwischen
seiner raus boden hütte und einem
sessellift der titlisbahnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in jeder freien stunde ist hanspeter
wenger der unternehmer aus internaten
auf der ängste leib
er legt selber hand an um seine gäste zu
bewirten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und um den könig herauszufordern und
auch der endstand ein neues reich zu
begründen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im hotel ängsten alb sind die
skiausflüge unterdessen zurückgekehrt
eine letzte gelegenheit die landschaft
zu bestaunen
bevor man immer das abendessen serviert
bevor der holländerin das jassen
beigebracht wird und fritz immer über
den nachbarn schimpft pwc schon
bearbeitet holz mit motorschlitten von
der puren mix etwas ja stellte ganze
maschine porto verkäufers und der natur
pur und unterm auto verstauen oder
besonders und dann wird es lacht auf der
engsten und nur noch zwei lichtlein
brennen auf der verwunschenen alb eines
gehört der ross boden hütte eines gehört
dem hotel engstlenalp die beiden wir sie
zu sprechen nur noch über die gerichte
miteinander
trotzdem ist der streit nicht nur die
auseinandersetzung zweier stura bergler
beim kampf um die engsten alb geht es
auch um die zukunft der bergwelt und
dahinter verbergen sich alte geschichten
die auch die sprinter handelsrunde nach
silber umgekehrt wie das gelände
umrundete vier jahren nutzt wurde ist
das auch immer um den transport sicher
verwahren
um im norden berichtet kommt sie wieder
und immer wieder vom norden natürlich
danke der wichtige rolle spielt wie sie
unter dem hauptbahnhof bassist und dann
auch ihren ausgangsort für sich entweder
von sie wieder ruhig geworden dass man
vorne keine haute so geschnitten oder
umgekehrt wieder dass man hier
volkstrauertag richtig sie wieder und
natürlich sehr weh tut sich was im
gegenteil ist ein bisschen das nächste
dorf und das ist natürlich ein
wunderbarer platz sieht und man weiß ja
alles ist faszinierend hantiert auch das
ist ein grund für das 1
[Applaus]
wie in alten zeiten empfängt der
hausherr die räume selber vor allem
runden einfach jugend sieht die single
bis 60 eine dahinter die filme technik
habe vorher nur natur hat primitiv ehren
herzens zu krabbeln und das ich muss
auch linux
die begegnung mit dem säubern weg
erinnerung was wirklich dahinter
das ist ja so dass zum beispiel die open
etat sei von den augen verloren haben
äußerte mehr verbessert wenn die dritten
ist sie unter soldan grafik sie dass ich
ein glücklicher stufe gesehen dass ich
es wieder aktivieren
und jetzt in den boxen und wenn ich dann
meistens alleine so gesehen dass wenn
die noble korstick respektive projekt
schon ins bett gehen dass der termin
aber gerade noch bis in die ecken werden
bis 3
es ist ganz klar nicht startachse eine
sehr gute qualität
heute hüten auf der engstlenalp sechs
älpler insgesamt 171 kühe und 125 rinder
für sie beginnt die arbeit lange bevor
der tag erwacht
[Musik]
ein sommer morgen auf der ängstlich
[Applaus]
in der frühe
bevor die ersten ausflügler den ängsten
sie erreichen setzt der kantonale
fischereiaufseher die jede woche 300
saiblinge aus damit die fischer später
auch etwas zu beißen
[Applaus]
inzwischen sind die kühe gemolken und
können ins freie
die ängste ist eine der größten alben
der schweiz
sie wird mit vier aus den gemeinden
innertkirchen und hasliberg gestoßen
kurt limacher kommt aus dem kanton
obwalden in den sommerferien sind auch
patrick und michi auf der alt die kinder
seiner partnerin heidi ried liegt die
übrigen eltern kommen aus schaffhausen
deutschland südtirol und co
auch bert mora ist unterwegs er ist so
sein offizieller titel der alb vogt und
muss versuchen die interessen der 37
genossenschafter unter einen hut zu
bringen
[Musik]
das rechte knie fehlt und professor wir
sie hier
früher hätten wir den sack aber heute
ist der alto zufrieden
eine lehrlings gruppe aus dem unterland
leistet fronarbeit es ist eher
aufgestockt die welt die ich wenig
begangene letzten jahr
wir hätten ihm abgewendet und der hohen
margen hätten mitgemacht das gras war
beträchtlich gewachsen
hans fritschi setzt sich an der seite
von fritz immer für die erhaltung der
engsten alm ein
er kämpft gegen hanspeter wenger und
sein komitee das die engsten touristisch
entwickeln möchte fritschi ist lehrer an
der gewerbeschule und naturschützer bei
pro natura der wichtigsten airlines
über land hält tourismus dass man
grundlage nicht wieder kaputt macht so
einzigartig gut erhalten
was mir ein besonderes anliegen ist es
natürlich hier die pflanzenart die mama
zum teil hier noch hey was zum teil 1
anderen ort als gestalter sie dass wir
den klassenerhalt
das ist das ist bei mir liegt ganz fest
zu
aber jetzt will den schon fast üblichen
das hat mich nie vor gericht seine
vorgänger hält das feld so macht ihr
euch der menge strecke kennt wird wohl
stimmen in mengen der krainhäger woher
das dass ich stehe das ist schon eine
von größte offene berger sagt der
seepolizei jahren bin ich im vorstand
mit rita jahre präsident jetzt vize
präsident von pro natura berner oberland
bin neu in der geschäftsleitung vom
kantonalen aber dies hier ist eigentlich
das schwierigste und war ohne haddorf
und das muss ich sagen er weiß dass der
hund ist auch nur ein cent also anderes
zu
[Musik]
die wanderer sind unterwegs
und auch freddy hukla der seine
kostbaren weißen alpen schafe auf der
ängste salat
[Musik]
am see unten sind trotz des frühen
einsatzes des fischerei inspektors nicht
alle fischer restlos glücklich
aber nützen
und wer auch immer auf die ängste
bekommt alle sind wie verzaubert von
diesen sagenhaften ort ernst oppenberger
sich schon seit jahren in ängsten sie
wenn ich dort das panorama rondo
mallorca muss ich sagen das ist
paradiesisch
und das geht in der schweiz press net es
zwar tritt immer hat er je in vierter
generation verliert sogar kurz die
fassung wenn er seine gefühle hier oben
beschreiben soll
ja ich glaube etwas ist das ist das
credo der fans an dem fritz immer sitzt
ist der kraft stein der engsten und
anhänger esoterischen lehren haben
herausgefunden dass er so viel energie
verströmt wie die pyramiden von gizeh
ein eigenes mikroklima lässt die armen
bis in eine höhe von 2000 meter wachsen
und nirgendwo in der schweiz findet man
so viele enziane wie auf der engstlenalp
aber fast scheint es als ob alle
positive energie in die natur ströme
und das klima unter den menschen dafür
umso schlechter sein
alle haben streit miteinander schritt
immer hat streit mit jenen die auf der
alb etwas verändern möchten
ich bin eigentlich verpasst
das ist jetzt viel witz aber ich bin
irgendwie hefe vermietern oder gar kein
jahr in einer gastrolle für mich
natürlich nicht irgendwo man als nutzer
die abo und lead sängers leib trug
sondern dem thema so nutz und astaro
devot nutzen sparen geld und
zusatznutzen dann musst du voll und ganz
hinter gitter die fahrer und mitfahrer
verläuft ja in zehn oder so aber auch
fritz immer war dem gedanken des
naturschutzes nicht immer
uneingeschränkt zugetan glock für das
projekt was man sehr und da kommt und
das projekt vom naturschutz inspektorat
abklären wurde mit der begründung dass
man eigentlich dass seehofer das aber
sei sie wie sich und wo dann ein
minister sage ja jetzt natürlich den
sparkurs nicht will und gemeint das
nichtwählen der müssen wir doch zum
rostocker zoo der dem einfach niemals
ich machen was ich schon so krank und
deshalb hat er jetzt streit mit dem
albbad moore große liegt das eigentlich
daran dass die idee das monopol der
wirtschaftsbetrieb manko das ist ja auch
noch die sache macht's gut aber
es ist einfach nicht so dass niedrige
hüten ohne handels und eine qual betrieb
was ich mit einem resümee
doch recht rosa kugel dass sie stammte
ja noch nie hat daher die problem dass
er das einiges aus bekämpft wer hat
moore der alb voigt besitzt eine
alphütte auf der engstlenalp die er zum
wochenendhäuschen ausgebaut hat er hat
aus streit mit dem naturschützer hans
fritschi die stadt hemer
was mich stört ist dass diese fünf
spielern aus die einzige wofür natur
locker wenn ich verfolge was mir machen
was vorher gemachte das hat diese völlig
legitim wo liegt vor zur sache sie und
meine sie hält mit der natur wenig
beachtet als stur und sei der
naturschutz hans verschieden sagen seine
gegner
das braucht aber mit genoni und
bezüglich schaffe mir ist viel verliert
in den gegner risiko für dich direkt auf
der andere seite könnte sich der ärger
des tritts und ist jetzt gefragt was sie
von ist halten schilthornbahn zum
beispiel die jungfraubahnen wir bestens
mit seiner schaffens und 14 vorlagen
vollendete tatsachen stellt sich zum
teil illegal dort verhalten oder ob man
super folge
[Musik]
was aussieht wie das paradies ist
zerrissen das klima auf der engstlenalp
ist so vergiftet dass selbst bauern und
älpler krach haben untereinander wurde
die produkte wie verstöße sind und ja es
ist einfach als besonderen drückt oder
her ob er die sache für mich kunst und
unternehmen das einfache aber viel zu
groß und der bruder klappt es denn
wenigstens unter den älplern kontakt zu
stellen was um himmels willen läuft den
schief weil die replik
[Musik]
das ist so scharf wie immer braucht es
allerdings auch hier zum streiten zwei
[Musik]
bernhard kaufmann der älpler aus
schaffhausen ist ausgebildeter bauer und
sozialarbeiter bevor die arbeit
aufnahmen warnte ihn sein bauer das auf
eine schwierige alb kämen und
und ich merke jetzt aber irgendwohin
also in einem brandbrief wird den habe
ich mir und ich habe die zeit ich werde
das nehmen und wenn das einmal warten
und den ewigen ortszeit tankstelle ob
könig oder aber ich kann ich nur
bestehen wenn du nicht das mögliche und
und er mich schon gut würde dann geht es
gegen abend zwei auf der engstlenalp
schlechtes wetter kündigt sich an der
elbe
der aus polen gekommen ist wohl die kühe
in den stall und vielleicht weiß ja gar
nicht wie viel glück hat dass er kein
deutsch versteht und nur mit seinen
kühen reden kann
wieder herrscht hochbetrieb in den
ställen 2400 liter milch werden zum
anfang der allzeit täglich zur
schaukäserei gebracht dem stolz und dem
verhängnis der engsten leute über
jahrhunderte hinweg machten die älbler
ihren käse selber
doch dann kamen neue anforderungen des
globalen absatzes mit vielen
vorschriften und so beschlossen die
eidgenossen zu beginn des dritten
jahrtausend gegen großen inneren
widerstand eine gemeinsame käserei zu
errichten
der bau für die anlage die nur vier
monate im jahr offen ist wurde über eine
halbe million franken teurer als geplant
seither lässt die verschuldete
genossenschaft nach jedem franken den
sie zusätzlich einnehmen kann
bei der käserei treffen sich für jeden
tag die beiden streitbaren älpler kurt
limacher und bernhard kaufmann heute
endet ihre begegnung schließlich aber
auch ihr streit ist das echo davon dass
eine alte ordnung zusammengebrochen ist
und sich eine neue noch nicht
definierter
auch wenn sich die neuen kräfte mit
aller macht zurück wenn trommler
teichler und geisel körper erobern die 1
fast sieht es so aus als seien die
älpler und bauern zum aufstand gegen den
könig angetreten sie deren vorfahren die
stube des hotels ersten halt nicht
betreten durften
es ist los schwingfest auf ängste
organisiert vom ehemaligen mutterboden
und heutigen garagisten hanspeter wenger
[Gelächter]
er kennt hier jeden und jede klopft
darauf eine schulter schüttel dort hände
weibelt das festgelände an diesem
schwingfest wochenende ist hanspeter
wenger der herr der engstlenalp
die wenig oder interessant ging
der schwede know how für den
erfolgreichen tag hoffen auf zwölf jahre
wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tokio
[Musik]
aber während die jungen leute im
sägemehl ihre kräfte messen geht es auf
der terrasse von james ross boden hütte
um einen ganz anderen hosenlupf
zahlreiche politische prominenz ist hier
versammelt mitstreiter von hanspeter
wenger vereint in einem komitee haben
sie das ziel die touristische
entwicklung der engstlenalp
voranzutreiben der verschuldeten käserei
neue einnahmequellen zu sichern und dem
könig fritz immer ein bein zu stellen
[Applaus]
das 8
das sagte die nummer 1 zu einem
hauptanliegen der gruppe sondern dass
das nachbarland schweiz habe der 50
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die jodler besingen einen frieden den es
vielleicht gar niger denn die älbler auf
der engsten wahl immer bedroht vom
dunklen gefahren wie fred jaggi weiß der
alte hass italia sagen sammelt das war
das hebt es jungs meint li xin aber wohl
aber im unterschätzen anderem nach der
geist körper und das ist eine private
lokale nationalpreis aber westend juni
lief ist wenn dann rutscht nachrichten
externes details weiß wo die mit
leiterin ist somit der basilius cliff
das entleeren das ist jetzt nach
erkenntlich gang weiter zu stärken und
so ziehen fast wie in einem alten heimat
film dunkle wolken auf über der
engstlenalp
[Musik]
blitz und donner finden unheil an
bis weit in die nacht hinein gibt der
sturm keine ruhe
[Musik]
wetterumsturz auf der engstlenalp es ist
august und der schnee ist tief gefallen
an den durchnässten steilen hängen kommt
das vieh ins rutschen kommt lena holt
die kühe in tiefere lagen drei tiere hat
er bereits verloren und er zum free
tibet reisen hittnau wiederholt sie also
mehr wachstum und danach passiert das
ist einfach so aber nicht immer können
sich die großen katastrophen mit blitz
und donner an und keiner weiß das besser
als fritz immer so ist
oktober station ängsten boden nicht so
dass eine station ängsten bonn.de dass
justitia
neben kuwait bis zu deinem höchste der
torburg selben fleck dass der golfsport
daher wo man dort ruft verstarb bisher
viel ausdauer station mussten drei große
skigebiete wollen sich im herzen der
schweiz zu einem neuen schneeparadies
zusammentun
dazu braucht es eine bahn welche die
engsten alb dem wintersport erschließen
soll am 1 es ist dieses projekt dass
fantasien weckt einerseits von neuen
geldquellen für die verschuldeten alb
genossen und andererseits von untergang
und verderben und den massenmord werke
was führt zukunft nicht für die
unmittelbare zukunft die verlängerung
sie masters für tourismus bietet ist es
besser für tourismus weil die bauern
noch einmal oder schlachter dass so
wenig habe urteil also weniger gäste
kennt mittlerweile die extra auf der
stelle ich will nichts mag das einfach
etwas ganz spezielles und bass und das
segment selten gott in dieser region
sollten das unbedingt wehren und nico
machen
doch könnte denn nicht gerade fritz
immer aus seinem hotel eine goldgrube
machen wenn da eine neue bahn neue gäste
zu führen würde das ist absolut
berechtigt die frage typisch doch
eigentlich centers halte spitzel die
anders als genug rollen
ob er selber lieben mode wie den
einzigen wo man in baden ruppel und es
einfach vornehmen und das ohne zum
wohnraum und platz machen
ich glaube das war damals natürlich mit
einem märz erfahren ob mit einem nicht
unbedingt sein widersacher garagist
hanspeter sänger ist in der herbstlichen
morgen früh mit gewehr und feldstecher
unterwegs die wohnung die sich nicht
weit man die meter 28 jahre geht es auch
noch um den befehl zum 50er jahre bau
beauftragt hätten sich gefragt und und
rief gemacht ich habe meine es klärt
aber mit diesen 15 jahre sauber kassel
im winter bin ich viel taxi und nach
einer skifahrerin fahrer wohl auch das
liftfahren prozent 14 kollegen und das
neben hoffer kabel und nach einem
rückgang macht und die machen das st
es ist ja das lied nein
[Applaus]
die rosa posten hinter seiner ross boden
hütte bereiten hanspeter wenger keine
sorgen wenn die bauern rund um die
ziemlich viel strom denn das mit
nachhaltiger tourismus niemals aufgeben
unternehmen um die mit dem strom
schwimmen und nicht gar gestohlen
wenn das tier und metaller portmonee
notiere mittlerweile suspendiert worden
und befürworter des bundesheers
schneeparadies
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann kommt der winter die schaukäserei
hat geschlossen jetzt es die engsten alt
wieder weit weg gerückt
nur mit dem schnee turf erreichbar oder
wie tourenski im hotel engstlenalp fritz
immer für seine gäste seine frau
marianne hat jetzt zeit für die
büroarbeiten zusammen mit dem verband
pro natura hat die hotelierfamilie
beschwerde eingereicht gegen die
gemeinde innertkirchen
mit der änderung des zonenplans hat
diese dem hans peter benger den schnee
taxibetrieb erlaubt hat die hände woche
oder einfach nicht
es macht aus bewusst dass ich ja
meistens situation intensiv jemand fritz
ist so unversöhnlich wie immer sich die
zehn fonds der goldenen henne für die
privatsphäre und die courage widmen und
der freude sein gegner denkt nicht daran
in der ross boden hätte bewirtet
hanspeter wenger seine gäste
[Gelächter]
nur mit dem nachbarn spricht er nicht
mehr was ich meine
als prima mit
[Applaus]
mit dem segen der gemeindeversammlung
von innertkirchen holt hans peter benger
seine gäste mit dem schnee tief vom
ängstlichen lift und bringt sie auch
dorthin wieder zurück zwei kilometer hin
zwei kilometer zurück seit vielen jahren
erlaubt es der lift den skifahrern von
engelberg aus über den jochpass bis zum
westlichen rand der engstlenalp
vorzustoßen
[Musik]
der jochpass gehört zum bereich der
titlisbahnen dem größten schneesport
helga rabl der zentralschweiz und nur
allzu gerne möchte die ambac trübsee
titlis ag ihr geschäftsfeld weiter ins
berner oberland ausbauen
fernziel ist der zusammenschluss mit
meiringen hasliberg und melchsee frutt
zu einem zusammenhängenden skigebiet
vorerst möchten sich die titlisbahnen
auf der engstlenalp nun diesen
sonnenhang erschließen
das schaf tal das bis ins herz der
engsten alb vorstößt der rummel der
talstation in unmittelbarer nähe des
hotels gelegen würde die winterliche
ruhe der engsten alb brutal verändern
deshalb löst das 18 millionen projekt
heftige emotionen aus im hotel
engstlenalp treffen sich hans fritschi
vorstandsmitglied von pro natura und
albert wiler der direktor der
titlisbahnen darum für das schloss sich
sicher der hat was mir heute existieren
die sagen mittelgroße skigebieten und
remmidemmi zehn prozent was über denzler
erzielt luft und dann auch sicher
möglich ist also technisch möglich ist
selber und technisch am besten man sich
möglich denn hätte dass du es wirklich
dass mir international langfristig
konkurrenzfähig wäre sie geblieben
das beinhaltet natürlich auch
volkswirtschaftliche überlege das heißt
die randregionen positiv ruth aus einer
bar kapital kommen überlegte was möchte
mir die 20 uhr igs gehen oder tourismus
ist früheste hauptgrundlage zum
überleben und der marktkräfte nicht das
gefühl dass gerade die große projekt das
großprojekt war hier planen ist dass das
im grund war der grund weiter die
intakte landschaft zerstört oder mit
grundlage von von wirtschaftlichen und
vom leben thailändischer so eine schöne
punkte und ist kühlen
das war aber noch ein link nicht nur um
so mit dem postauto hier im netz halten
situationen wo man nicht wo man nicht
einfach so kompromiss können für
inselstaaten vermutlich längste fund ja
das glaube ich auch es geht kann indem
sie entweder machen muss
aber die piste sind die lücke mit der
herr es geht wenn man verliebt aber ich
danke der ausdruck monster tourismus
sollte negativ sondern also die dem sehr
positiv sie blüht wunderschöne geben
können suchen
noch bleibt dieses privileg jenen
vorbehalten die sich mit eigenen kräften
vorwärts bewegen
[Musik]
und denen es reicht nur ganz leicht an
der großen natur zu zupfen ohne aussicht
auf belohnung
und dann wird es nachts auf der engsten
nur noch zwei lichtlein brennen auf der
verwunschene innerhalb eines gehört der
rosco blüte eines gehört im hotel
ängsten alt die beiden besitzer haben
sich nichts mehr zu sagen in dieser
geschichte in der es keine mitte gibt
und keinen kompromiss
[Musik]